um from there you do you go to jay sock
um you take over as the deputy commander
and
i think uh you you you throw out
um in nc stories you give an example
which i think is a
well it's it's a pretty important story
there's
a mission going on you're in the uh
you're in the talk
the tactical operation center and here
we go i'm gonna go to the book this is
from sea stories unbeknownst
to me lieutenant colonel bill coltrip
that's right
the sea squadron commander and colonel
jim hickey from 1st brigade 4th infantry
division
had maneuvered farther up the dirt road
from wolverine 1 which was one target to
another small house
designated wolverine 2. as i watched the
isr feed from the west cam
and listened to the radios the visual
and verbal
didn't match up wolverine 1 appeared
reasonably quiet
but the radio calls from coltrip sounded
like they were moving rapidly on a
target
it sounds like they're on target lee i
don't see any movement outside the house
i motioned to the jock non-commissioned
officer who sat at the end of the
long wooden table that made a horseshoe
around the isr screen
so you're sitting there watching this
thing unfold the isrs what's what's
the feed that's coming from the aircraft
overhead he was also on the headset
seeing what i was seeing which was
nothing
i raised my hands in the universal sign
of wtf
and he shrugged and called back isr is
on the target i don't know where the
squadron is sir
i hated to call the squadron in the
middle of an operation
and and that's an important point um you
know from a
from from my perspective you know i was
a platoon commander and assault force
commander and a platoon and then a task
unit commander
and the fact that you weren't jumping on
there hey where are you at what's going
on what's going on
is is i'd say if you've got a boss
you've got at least a 50
chance of a boss that wants to know
exactly where you are at all time and
it's
not fun and it doesn't help and so here
you are you say i hated to call the
squad in the middle of an operation
it's the last thing any tactical guy on
the ground wants a call from his boss
sitting warm and comfortable in a jock
50 miles away from the action
still it was our responsibility to
manage the quick reaction force and the
medical evacuation if something went
wrong on target
that was hard to do if you didn't have
good situational awareness of the
mission
and the truth was i was curious as to
whether this new lead was panning out so
they were tracking a lead
somewh somewhat reluctantly i pushed the
talk i pushed the talk button and
reached out to coltrip
bill are you on target yes sir culture
responded somewhat excitedly
we don't see you on isr there was a
pause on coltrip's end
sir we are on wolverine2 just down the
road from the original target
and we have jackpot jackpot jackpot
jackpot was the code word meaning they
had captured the objective
at first i assumed coltrap meant case is
that who you were looking for
but suddenly it occurred to me that the
tone of culture of
voice indicated something more
significant jackpot
do you mean little jackpot or big
jackpot
big jackpot culture of answered and
going um as this goes forward big
jackpot was salaam
right so these guys had just captured
saddam
and i was actually i was in iraq at the
time and
and so we had found out i think we had
found out
we found out really quickly one of the
guys that we were working on the oga
guys we were working out
with was one of the early um
interrogators on him and come down yeah
we got him so as much as
i know you were trying to keep it secret
there was
uh it didn't stay so it didn't really
secretly
that one didn't say stay secret very
long i know there's a
there's uh before we jump in a little
bit about saddam so
when you when you were running that
earlier i mentioned you were running
this
project of like looking at the future of
warfare and what we could do and i was
part of that
so i was and there was like five of us
and you were basically taking us and
sending us to all these
uh very cool probably some of the best
schools i ever went to i went to lock
picking and car stealing and
just all these really cool stool uh
schools to get us prepared to do like
you said operations from a totally
different perspective
and i remember i i sat through your
brief a couple times
and you would brief you know some senior
officers and you'd say hey listen
in the seal teams we do direct action
but we have tea lambs now
and so do we really need to do direction
or are we really going to have to do
direct action missions
when we've got telomers and we've got
another thing we do is
special reconnaissance well are we
really going to do need to do special
reconnaissance when we've got satellites
and
and we've got you know uav capabilities
that are coming on board
and and you know i remember like i said
i was a young guy and thinking okay well
i need to i need to transfer to this new
format we're not going to do direct
action anymore
i think the next time i saw you i was in
baghdad you came down to camp jenny
posey where we were
we were i was jocked up literally about
to go out of my
whatever 50th or whatever direct action
mission and and uh i thought it was
funny i kind of smiled to myself said
well looks like
we're still doing it looks like we're
still doing it sir um
but but this this mission got saddam and
then
man you you do a it's a very interesting
perspective i mean how
how how crazy is it to sit here and talk
to you
you were interacting with saddam when he
got captured
and you detailed in the book but i mean
just some some high level thoughts what
was that like
detailing with this freaking horrible
horrible
sadistic person yeah it was very
interesting because the um
you know when we first captured him i
mean he was pompous he was arrogant
uh when uh when bill called back when
bill culture called back and said hey we
got a big jackpot good to your point you
had asked about case so case was the guy
we were
the facilitator so we were trying to get
the facilitator who we thought was going
to lead us to saddam
well they had gotten case and then case
had kind of pointed them toward saddam
and they opened the spider hole you've
seen the picture
saddam's in there so they bring saddam
back to crit
and and i'm i'm down in baghdad and um
and so now we had a plan okay what do
you do if you get saddam well i had to
call general abzade who was the centcom
commander called john mcchrystal who was
my boss back in
tampa and i had to make plans to well we
want to we want to verify that saddam so
i needed to get
dna sent to you know the lab and fbi lab
and all that sort of thing
but but as all this is happening
um uh uh the uh the jtf commander
um general rick sanchez i get the word
joel sanchez is outside the jock i was
like
what i mean he was the big guy in iraq
time three star at the time
and uh so we'll bring him on in so
sanchez comes in sits
down beside me and says uh bill i
understand you got
uh saddam i said hey sir i do not know
that yet
uh yeah i'm not gonna call jackpot until
i can
see it till we can verify it you know
how this goes you know there are a lot
of times uh we had captured guys
who we thought had the right name the
cunys were different people were
different
you called jackpot then you're
embarrassed you know 24 hours later
when's not the right guy
and he says you know i mean i i heard
through uh you know
through oga that that you got him i said
well sir he'll be down here in 30
minutes
you can see for yourself i think we both
just spotted the leak huh
well so uh so the uh about 30 minutes
later the helo arrives
well i mean i'm busy making phone calls
so i turn to my
uh chief of staff who i call him i think
captain lee at his request
um and i said hey go over there you got
to come back and and i'm trusting you to
tell me whether you think it's saddam or
not so
he and general sanchez go over there and
he comes back a few minutes later he
goes
started saddam and said okay so now i'm
calling abbas and doing my sort of thing
well about uh you know half an hour
later i i go back over there
and i remember talking to sanchez it was
kind of one of those funny moments so
saddam has this big beard
and uh and i realized we got to get him
cleaned up because we're going to have
this kind of press release and
everything and
frankly it looked like saddam even with
a big beard i mean he's got this bulbous
nose and everything
but i figured well let's get him cleaned
up so no iraqis can say it's not saddam
so i turned to one of the guys that said
okay let's get him shaved
and uh and get him cleaned up and then
we'll take a picture and then we'll
be able to compare the yeah so as i'm
saying
sanchez turns to me says i don't know
bill do we have the authority to shave
him
i said sir we had the authority to kill
him if he was you know
if he was trying to get us i think we
got the authority to shave him we both
kind of laughed
i really liked rick sanchez he was a
good guy um
so we so i go off make some more phone
calls i come back assuming that what had
happened was
some ranger or somebody had had gotten
the shears and was kind of clean and
said i mean why come back
saddam's got a pair of scissors in his
hand and he's clipping his own beard i'm
like
no let me have those scissors yeah just
yeah pull those away and he's like
well i was told to get cleaned up but
but the next
the next day was the day when you you
recall the press conference
uh where the ambassador and joel sanchez
say we got him
well they hadn't seen him yet uh uh
sanchez had seen him but the ambassador
hadn't seen him yet so they fly out to
uh
to our place there in baghdad and go to
to see saddam and they brought some of
the iraqi leaders with them
and again saddam i've you know i've got
him now in a jumpsuit and he's sitting
on a cot
but when they when the iraqi leaders
came into the room small
room about this size actually i mean
they are yelling at him they're spitting
at him
and he's got this look on his face like
boys i'm still in charge here
sit down any kind of motions to him you
guys just sit down
don't you know who i am and i'm looking
thinking wow
he is he still thinks he's in charge
he's about to find out he's no longer in
charge you know
so uh i didn't really want to bring
those guys in because i knew this would
happen it would just bolster his ego
so after uh after they left i talked to
sanchez and knocked him back
i said sir that's it i don't want
anybody else buzzing him
i am responsible for him now uh i mean
and
called john labzade he will tell you i'm
responsible for him so here's what i'm
telling you
nobody else visits him um we will you
know i will take good care of him
but i don't want him you know feeling
like he's somebody important over the
next 30 days i held on to him
and in the room i had a an officer and a
security guy and a and a medic and or a
doctor at all times with him because he
was 67 years old he had all sorts of
health problems
but it was interesting to watch as as
the days and weeks went on
and he no longer had his you know
palaces and he no longer had his
generals he no longer had his
handmaidens
he really just became a pathetic old man
um
and uh and every time i'd come in every
i'd go check on him every day
he'd always stand up to want to talk to
me i would say
no and i wouldn't talk to him and it
made him mad and he would talk to the
rangers and the
and the doc and i told him i said i
don't want anybody
saying a word to him um and he would
always ask about el jefe
yeah yeah el jefe and of course i came
in i made sure my stars weren't on and
my name tag wasn't on
but he knew who i was yeah i mean just
by yeah you command it
so 30 days into it it was time to move
him
and i was really hoping that by this
time you know the insurgency had really
had kind of blossomed he didn't know
that of course um and i thought well
let's see if i can get him to
tell the insurgents to stand down so we
had a plan
uh brought my translator in and of
course i knew what his answers would be
but i figured
i got nothing to lose here so i sat down
with him and i said
look you know the kind of the war is
over here the americans have come in
we've
and he just kind of nodded and i said
but your people are still dying
and you know you can do one of two
things you can become benito mussolini
and be the petty dictator or you can do
right by your country now
it's not going to end well for you you
got to know that but
tell them to lay down their arms so so
we're not killing any more iraqis
and i knew he'd ask me the question that
i thought he would ask he said
if it was you would you do it and
and i said look you know if it was for
the best part of my country
i'd do what it took to save my country
and he looks at me goes
i don't think so he in arabic but it was
true
i knew what he meant and then i said to
him i said
okay you're not going to see me again
we're moving you
and he was like because we we've been
taking pretty good care of him
and he was like oh this is not a good
idea and so then he starts to get a
little talked if i said
time's done and uh so that night
we undercover darkness we moved him to
some military police and they held on to
him until the
until the trial but watching his
again watching him and his behavior and
how it changed when he no longer felt he
was
in a position of power it was i think
important to realize
you know that that's what you do you
know you're booked back on bullies
you know at the end of the day you stand
up to the bullies
and if all they had was the trappings
around them they're
they're not the kind of people that are
going to be able to stand up to you for
very long
and you know he was a function of the
generals that supported him and all of
the trappings and
when you took that away he was just a
bully